hello and welcome to this video playing
last 75 zero probably and we don't know
why he is going to play okay now that
makes sense at the moment I'm
threatening e5 to go with this setup
that I'm playing here is slightly
dubious for black slightly but it leads
to the unconventional play okay yeah I
think I am this actually what I
recommended for what even though I
wonder why exactly can I not take
you
mmm-hmm this is very tempting to take a
central pawn
I didn't quite see why not see takes it
takes screen a four I have knight c6
yeah and he okay I mean it's clear that
he's got some play but how dangerous is
it yeah now just the simplest one yeah
do it I wonder if I should go Bishop g4
insert this he has no real he doesn't
have a good reply with the rook and f3
is not a move that you want to play well
yeah maybe you can play route d3 but
it's not yeah now he takes d5 I have
Bishop f5
ship f5 Jake
[Music]
maybe d6 but I got 95 No
okay so Bishop takes c3 Bishop f5
doesn't net much I mean I can't just do
this of course and keep the keep the
pawn with a really nice pollution
actually the knight on d5 is very strong
it's nicely anchored and so what is he
doing Bishop g5 maybe
ya hear night before is simply simply
strong I mean maybe maybe add something
else but this is more or less deciding
deciding no decisive now or rather
rather look eh I don't know thinking too
long is probably the biggest mistake I
can make in terms of moves probably just
not really
I can check now
now can we how come to how to win this
taking okay let's let's do this this is
I think enough maybe maybe there was
something even stronger but oh now that
that I completely overlooked a stupid I
thought he has to go okay one which is
of course totally totally idiotic a
totally idiotic idea that he would need
to do that I mean the idea actually
still works the ideas to box in his rook
the rook still has absolutely no way out
it is quite quite funny actually he has
no way to get the rook out and this is
nice
yeah I was a bit odd yeah Quincy too is
probably mistimed I mean I don't know
what I recommended here for white I
think III maybe after I kind of remember
III at some stage yeah I think I don't
know I think I can take it
okay the engine does not agree okay it
basically says that here Queen a4 and 93
is good for white okay so let's say I do
this
yeah okay Bishop h6 that is absolutely
true um now I'm stuck in the middle and
there is he for coming at some point
yeah okay then my pawn grab was was bad
no no I'm no I'm okay
he's got probably enough development to
to be okay I shouldn't take I think I
thought maybe Bishop g5 or something
like that even though there is deform
yeah it's fine for me it's fine yeah but
this is this is giving me a huge
advantage the main reason is that the
knight on d5 is so strong I was
expecting Bishop g5 he played this and
now night before is I think just
decisive he has to take and this is this
is basically forced okay eight okay I
have one I can't if one is it's not
helping I he has to play something like
this after which my extra pawn should do
it in the long run but it's still a
technical task and him he's completely
boxed in so I seem okay
this is strong yeah that's true
threatening this and he has no way to
stop it okay and if if he goes rook a
one then you could actually transpose to
what I was planning I wanted to get this
position with my line what I did I only
had this in mind and then Knight c4 is
basically stay awaiting him
yeah the the rook is tied to this and
yeah the the the only way to get the
rook in the game is this theoretically
now he is sitting on a one which is yeah
funny okay I overlooked this but it's
it's it's just crazy look still is is
without squares you know it has
absolutely nowhere to go covered covered
covered you can go here but that doesn't
help so he's basically running out of
moves I can just go up and and push the
a pawn home it's okay okay guys thanks
for watching